[Music]
this 2016 yeah exactly where you said
you'd be I'm sorry who exactly are you
my name is Rex Tyler I'm a member of the
Justice Society of America the actual
JSA the single greatest secret force
this country has ever known I need to
talk to you about Sara Lance Ray Palmer
and the rest of the legends I think
they're wrong someone just blew up New
York during World War two
I think we can all guess who that
someone is we are history's last line of
defense we have the tools to make a
difference we can make history better as
in seducing the Queen of France she
seduced me I'm gonna get to meet Albert
Einstein well yeah but they started
we're not time masters there are no
rules you're not yet taken you me never
do someone either
it's like ninja 3 the domination there's
no such thing as ninjas you idiot
so that's a Chuck Norris
we'll have no idea what you're up
against hello via bird mr. dark relax
captain we got this
as flawed and unruly those who are
individually together you are the best
crew a captain could ever hope sorry to
contact you like this captain hunter but
I can't risk putting any more lives in
danger
now that you people have managed to kill
yourselves yet days - yo hey youtubers
is charlie so new legends of tomorrow
just a society footage we also see flash
arrow Supergirl 4 night crossover
footage - so let's break it down this is
finally the Justice League TV show that
we were promised or that they should
have done initially I don't know why
they just didn't start with this in
season 1 so yay for Justice Society
we're finally there they're doing core
characters so it's not like they can't
do actual Justice Society so I'll
explain who the roster is gonna be in
how Justice Society fits into the
continuity of earth 1 so we're talking
like the arrow verse we're not talking
like super girls earth which is still
like in a different universe so we
haven't seen season 1 you don't need to
watch it
it's a time-travel show you understand
it there used to be time masters they
basically killed them off via time
travel so now there are no cops
policing time travelers so you have
time-traveling criminals like the
reverse-flash
eobard thawne messing with time which is
where you get the Legion of Doom the big
bads of season 2 so it's just a society
versus Legion of Doom
so Legion of Doom all across history
just starts going crazy like you hear
they blow up New York with an atom bomb
during World War two and they're like Oh
guess who's responsible for that
it's damian darhk-- back in the 1940s so
like people that are dead in modern
continuity will show up in the past
sometimes so like they said katie
cassidy is gonna get star on the TV show
she's probably gonna show up in the past
Sarah finds out about her death probably
gonna try and save her somehow but
that's kind of like the MacGuffin of the
season you see citizens steal here the
way they talked about him in the trailer
it sounds like he doesn't know that he
has powers or he's hiding the fact that
he has powers but in the comics he has
kind of a tragic story he basically
turns into living steel so he loses his
sense of touch it becomes part of this
big plot where he gets twisted by one of
the villains I don't think they're gonna
go that way with this character he seems
a little more hopeful so I don't think
they're gonna be that pessimistic with
the story but you get the idea
living steel so he's the guy that comes
to Oliver in the trailer
like hey I think your friends are
totally messing up they're in trouble we
need to find them and help out so of
course Oliver Queen crossover in the
first episode
now the flash is finally officially
crossing over this season - and
everybody's like how come he didn't
crossover in season one they put him in
that first trailer while I wasn't eating
the rest of the series so we see
messages from future berry way further
in the future beyond that flash
newspaper from season one like flash
vanishes in crisis but it's during the
2020s just making you wonder how they're
gonna deal with that on the flash TV
show that's like a whole other thing but
this is from the 2050s so we're talking
to like a super old berry but remember
the Speed Force actually keeps the flash
pretty young like it rejuvenates his
cells so he ages much much slower than a
normal person but a lot of you were like
what does that mean I can't risk putting
any other lives in danger it's just like
a continuation of the Legion of Doom
versus just a society time-traveling
plot the reverse-flash going all
overtime influencing events Barry
naturally trying to chase him down so
this is Big Time war that's being waged
in different places in time and we're
seeing it through the legends Cruz eyes
so like when we jump through different
times we'll probably see different
versions of heroes that we've already
seen before so we might actually see
that really old version of Barry like we
got to see really old one armed Oliver
Queen last year we got to see connor
hawke we might get to see super old
Barry but more legends roster I know
there's lots of questions [ __ ] because
like vixen is a different version of
vixen it's basically her grandmother
just because there was a problem with
the actresses availability like the
person who played vixen before so this
is another person to wear the mantle
it's her grandmother but it looks like
they fixed the special effects or the
like way cooler so the way they
explained her she's just like a little
more hardcore but I totally loved her
costume obviously you know Mike from
suits he's playing our man Rex Tyler he
basically gets superpowers for an hour
at a time when he uses his drug but it's
super addictive so we'll see how they
deal with that that's star girl super
happy to see her back on TV haven't seen
her since the Smallville episode of
Justice Society which was written by
Geoff Johns so like a lot of these
Justice Society characters are actually
characters that appeared in Geoff Johns
Justice Society comic his JSA title if
you haven't read JSA read Geoff Johns
run from the early 2000s it's not gonna
be the exact same plot that they're
doing on the TV show but it'll give you
good background on the characters and
the artwork is amazing but you guys see
obsidian standing there in the
background we see him use his powers
during the trailer that's another big
WTF because they confirmed that this
obsidian is the son of Alan Scott but
obsidian is being played by Lance
Henriksen so if you imagine how old
Lance Henriksen is then imagine how old
Alan Scott must be so if we're gonna
actually hear Green Lantern's stuff
happening on the TV show it'll probably
be during like an extended obsidian
scene where he starts talking about his
backstory a little bit about his past
his family but just going around the
list here that's dr. midnight back
behind Stargirl
and the other guys standing over here on
the end is Sandman so that's just like
the beginning obviously we're in the JSA
brownstone so that's like a whole other
thing we'll have to talk about that when
we get to that episode but I feel like
the effects look awesome
it sounds like they actually know what
the plot is this season they added in a
bunch of flash characters and I know
everybody's like what about Jay Garrick
if they're doing reverse flash and Barry
and Jay Garrick was part of Justice
Society like a corps member then why
isn't he in the trailer I feel like
they're just holding that back you know
it may be so that it's like a surprise
or something but you can't do justice
society without at least doing a little
bit of Jay Garrick and I know we see
Supergirl in this footage too that's
because there's four night crossover
footage in here so the four night
crossover is the dominators coming for
earth that's why everybody has to team
up from all four shows so if you ever
wanted a reason to watch all four TV
shows they're all connected so it just
makes it a lot more fun for the
continuity of each of the seasons if you
keep up with the story each week but I
will be doing videos for everything so
no worries there Supergirl
starts on Monday legends of tomorrow
starts next Thursday so when I post
those videos I'll explain what's
different what they've done to make them
like way cooler they changed a bunch of
stuff on Supergirl
like we have Superman on Supergirl now
and we have just the society on legends
of tomorrow
that's not even getting into the for my
crossover stuff that's gonna be way
above and beyond anything you've seen on
TV before but if you want to start
getting ready for the four night
crossover it's the invasion storyline
it's by Todd McFarlane the guy that
created spawn but there are different
comic book Easter eggs that you're gonna
be seeing throughout the season on all
four TV shows from that dominator
storyline so as we go I'll explain what
they're doing
there's just like so much going on so
I'm so excited so if you're worried
about missing stuff don't worry
I'll try to include everything in the
videos that I do so even if you miss an
episode like you still be able to keep
up with what's going on but today the
really big news today the Iron Fist
panel is happening later at New York
Comic Con so I'll be doing a video
they're supposed to drop a new trailer
so I'll be doing a video for that later
be sure to subscribe to get it
all right so we've just wrapped in
season one of iron fist it's 9 a.m.
gonna be at Comic Con in like three
hours so I'm gonna get little just going
up and yeah I'll see you guys there I'm
really looking forward to it just need
to sleep alright peace there's another
flash killer frost video that I'm gonna
do later there's some new footage of
killer frost that's really badass so
whole bunch of stuff coming today New
York Comic Con is happening all week
there's some punisher stuff happening
later so next video should be iron fist
where you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for my justice league
trailer video and you can click here for
my last big flash trailer video thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight